[Musique]
dans la casbah d'alger où l'appel
impératif à la grève générale de 8 jours
lancée par le fln avait trouvé un écho
favorable
les forces du général massu chargés de
la sécurité ont dès le premier jour
lancé des sommations aux commerçants
dans ses ruelles où la rébellion a cru
trouver un nazi l'impénétrable partout
aux sommations se sont montrés inutile
les parachutistes ont levé les rideaux
de fer est ouvert les magasins fermés en
laissant en garde à la porte
[Musique]
les commerçants devaient bientôt
réintégrer leur boutique et reprendre
leurs activités comme la grève des
commerçants les autres grève ouverte sur
le mode en eau des rebelles ont fait
long feu
aucune activité ne s'est prouvé arrêté
et le nombre des grévistes s'est
amenuisé chaque jour la grève du fln la
boutique un échec
[Musique]